[Music]  thomas  [Music]  you seem particularly triggered right  now can you tell me what happened  i've had dreams that weren't just dreams  am i crazy  we don't use that word in here  [Music]  hi  [Music]  have we met  [Music]  one pill makes you larger and  one pill makes you small  and the ones that  mother gives you  don't do  anything  [Music]  time to fly  [Music]  [Music]  the only thing that matters to you is  still here i know it's why you're still  fighting  and why you will never give up  you don't know me  no  [Music]  how  [Music]  is  [Music]  [Applause]  king  [Music]  after all these years to be going back  to where it all started  back to the matrix  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you